prosecutors are building their case
against three white men charged with the
killing of 25 year old ahmad arberry
a black man you remember this story
we've been following it very closely on
cbs this morning
actually everybody's been covering this
story video released in may
more than two months after the shooting
shows that arberry was just jogging
in brunswick georgia investigators say
the three men followed and cornered him
and then one of them shot and killed him
omar villafranca conducted the first
in-depth network tv interviews with
attorneys on both sides for this week's
48 hours
it's got nothing to do with whether mr
arbury is white
black or martian attorney kevin goff
says his client
william roddy bryan was minding his own
business at home on february 23rd
when he saw a truck he recognized
pursuing a man
he didn't so he says brian got into his
own truck
and began following as quote any other
patriotic american would have done
end quote he's never been more than a
witness
to this shooting we think he's an active
participant
prosecutor jesse evans says the evidence
shows
brian did willingly help two other men a
father and son named gregory and travis
mcmichael
pursue and corner ahmad arbury in a
waterfront neighborhood in brunswick
georgia
brian was filming when travis mcmichael
killed arbory
with three shotgun blasts at point blank
range
any single shot was too much and just
merely pointing that shotgun at somebody
was too much
getting in pickup trucks and chasing a
mod arbory down was too much
this whole case is too much but travis
mcmichael's lawyers bob rubin and jason
sheffield say
the video shows ahmad arbury was the
aggressor that day
not travis he's being attacked and
overwhelmed
by ahmad arbury's strength and he has to
either
fire that gun or lose his life at that
point
that's going to be your defense that's
what happened
they say travis mcmichael was afraid
even though travis has a gun and a
vehicle and a mod arbory has two legs
you still can be afraid while you have
possession of a firearm clearly the
people that started this were
greg and travis mcmichael when they make
that choice that they're going to grab
guns and take the law into their own
hands that's when this crime starts it
doesn't start at the end of this
this whole progression out in the middle
of the street roddy bryant and the
mcmichaels have pleaded not guilty in
the death
of ahmad arbury
omar this story is still so painful for
many people watching you've been
covering the story from very
very early on what do you think happens
next
well right now the three men who are
accused of this they are still in jail
they're waiting for their trial
but gail we're in the middle of a
pandemic so we don't know when the trial
is going to start there's going to be
jurors they haven't even called the jury
pool
so it's anybody's guess when this trial
is going to start as for the arbury
family
they're just trying to keep his memory
alive
they don't have to worry about that a
lot of people will never forget ahmad
are berry thank you very much omar
you can watch omar's report justice for
ahmad on 48 hours tomorrow night at 10
9 central right here on cbs